all right everyone hello hello and
welcome back to the road to 2000
uh as always my name is caleb denby we
are missing
all the fancy bells and whistles for
tonight as my producer
ben simon has abandoned me for another
events
but we did get everything up and running
here sorry for the short delay in
getting started i had to solve
another crisis somewhere else on the
chess campus
never a dull moment here today but of
course
now we're up and running and the topic
for tonight is some
very fun very uh
interesting famous games in the night or
variation
throughout chess history the night or
has of course
a long and very interesting history and
it seems to be the opening of
world champions and all-time great chess
players so we're going to see how a few
all-time great chess players handled the
night or and wielded it
with great success and up first as you
can see on your screens
is going to be a game between two
legendary players
robert james fisher and mikhail tal
and in this game tal had the black
pieces and we're actually going to look
at it from
tal's perspective here so
to start off the game of course we have
the opening moves of the nydorf
uh e4 c5 knight f3 d6
d4 c takes d4 knight takes d4
and knight f6 knight c3 and now
a6 so you know the opening moves of the
open sicilian then knight f6
forces knight c3 and we have a6
denoting the night or now
a favorite of fisher uh against the
nightdorf
is this move that we see him play in the
game uh of course i'm talking about
bishop c4
uh for which he is co-named uh in the
variation it's called the fischer sozen
attack
quite quite often so he played it often
enough
to get it half named after him which is
is pretty nice
now with a6 in the night earth uh
usually black's plan
is to push this pawn up to e5 with the
point being
that there's no bishop b5 check followed
by knight
f5 to cause to cause black issues
however with bishop c4 it's kind of
anticipating the fact that e5 could come
and it's preparing the move knight f5
anyways here
white is able to play the move knight f5
because the common move for black to
refute this idea
is the move d5 you know taking advantage
of the fact
that this knight is underdefended here
on f5
so this pawn isn't able to control the
d5 square however of course with the
bishop on c4
this idea makes much less sense because
of course
white just has enough defenders of the
square thanks to this bishop
you can compare this with something like
bishop e2
when after e5 knight f5 d5 is just a
very good move
for black white is unable to capture as
black would capture and win a piece so
bishop c4 in the nightdorf is the
fischer sozen attack
playing against the typical night of
pawn push of e5
that being said black is happy now to
play the move e6
instead adopting a slightly different
setup now with e6
black uh is sort of laughing at white
for putting this bishop on c4
saying okay you want to attack the light
squares well i haven't played e5 just
yet
and i can play e6 to defend them very
very thoroughly
now quite often in this variation you'll
see black go for a move like b5
and bishop b7 or try some other way to
take advantage of this bishop
being on c4 sometimes d5 can happen
rarely
sometimes even just a queen c7 can gain
a tempo on the bishop
and for all those reasons it's quite
common to see white retreat this bishop
on this move
stepping out of any of those ideas uh
this is cheveningen now not quite this
is still the nidorf it's just
in response to the fischer susan trust
me trust me still the night or fear
so the bishop drops back to b3 and in
this game
tal chooses the move bishop e7 which
believe it or not
is something i sort of uh recommended i
believe
in my covering of the fischer susan
attack which
sort of led me to want to go over this
game
now white tries to attack in the typical
fischer sozen way with the move f4
why is this typical for the fischer
susan well like i was mentioning it's
all about the light squares
for white in this variation he puts this
bishop on this diagonal
he leaves this knight on d4 and now he's
trying to add a third attacker to the
light squares with a move like f5
and with f5 on the board the pressure on
e6 is going to become sort of
insurmountable and it's going to force
this pawn forward to e5
that's what white is hoping for here uh
in the game
tal did not flinch and simply castled
king's side
now the move f5 is playable immediately
but fischer saw no reason to rush and he
played the move queen f3 to start with
perhaps pointing out the fact that you
can't quite play the natural looking
b5 thanks to some e5 tactics in many
cases
with pressure on the rook and the knight
so
queen c7 is the preparatory move by
me tal to prepare the move b5 when after
e5
of course there is bishop b7 hitting the
queen
all very logical plays so far by both
sides black playing bishop e7
castling and then queen c7 which is a
direct preparatory move for the move b5
which of course
is the common way to gain counter play
in the nightdorf
now fischer again delays playing the
move f5
and goes for the move kingside castles
and i'm not sure kingside castles is my
favorite
i don't think white is worse out of this
uh
out of these opening moves but i do
think he hasn't applied too much
pressure
to black's position right out of the
opening which is something that
uh white should often kind of strive to
do in the fischer season because
you are making quite a lot of weaknesses
with this move f4
uh you are weakening the e pawn you were
weakening the second rank and you're
weakening this diagonal
right in the meantime black is not
really creating so many weaknesses
unless you put that pressure on him to
do so
so while i don't think white is too much
worse or even worse at all
in this position i do think that the
game could very quickly turn into
black's favor
if white isn't careful here so in the
game
tau continues very logically with the
move b5 why wouldn't you
you've prepared it with queen c7 and
this is your try for active counter play
and nowadays in these positions after b5
it's quite common to see the move a3
just to slow down this idea of b4
pushing the knight away
but fisher decided to play the move f5
very very directly here now i want you
guys at home to try and figure out
what the next sequence of moves is going
to be
for mihal tau it's black to move and
gain
an advantage in this position and try to
give me a sequence
of three moves or so what are black's
next
three moves because they're all very
very forcing moves
so you can quite easily calculate them
out
to to the next position so give me the
black's next three moves
to try and have an edge here what do you
guys think
uh qtoler asks why is this not also
on twitch those decisions are a little
bit above
my head unfortunately um i do remember
there being
some issue where we either weren't
allowed or weren't supposed to stream to
both youtube and twitch at the same time
but that's completely a guess on my part
i i
do not know the answers to these
questions
so chess king has the right idea but not
quite the correct order so of course
uh as i was mentioning earlier f5 puts a
ton of pressure on the e6 pawn
and it is very much in black's best
interest to push this pawn forward to e5
chess king also wants to push this pawn
forward to b4 and follow it up with
bishop b7 and this is
exactly the right idea for black you
sort of alleviate this pressure
on e6 you kick this knight away and you
put the bishop here where you can very
easily
pressure this now backwards e pawn for
white however if you play the move e5
first as chess thinker
suggested uh this knight will move out
of the way to knight e2
but after b4 you're in for sort of a
surprise when white can actually just
jump in
to this new newly opened d5 square
and white is not at all going to be any
worse if knight d5
can be achieved in this manner so
it's actually quite important that you
play the move b4
first and now the obvious downside to
this
is that uh bla
uh white is going to be able to play
this move f takes e6 and you have to be
ready to play this position
it turns out that maybe this is what
white should have gone for
but i do think black is going to be
pretty significantly better
after uh just the natural b takes c3
e takes f7 and king h8
it's not the easiest advantage in the
world but i do think it is some
advantage here
for black a pretty substantial advantage
in fact
look to see black try and untangle with
moves like knight bd7 and knight c5
the point being you want to defend e6
and try and take off this annoying
light squared bishop other than that
knight c6 is another idea to try and
trade these guys
bring the knight into e5 and at the end
of the day the pawn on f7
is likely not going to be living forever
with all of that in mind though fisher
was not quite ready to
part with this piece on c3 and played
the move knight a4
unfortunately now for white though he is
sort of just positionally
much worse in my opinion the move e5
comes on the board the knight retreats
to e2
and as chess king had suggested bishop
b7
and now the pressure on e4 is going to
be very very annoying
for white to deal with the knight comes
out to g3
and if you watched my chess openings
explained lecture on the najdorf
this is sort of the ideal uh position
that i was describing
in those those lectures black has
a ton of pressure on e4 and white is not
going to have any time to be launching
attacks on the king's side
as long as we are very consistently
uh launching this assault on the light
squares
fro from the black side uh the natural
move now
for black is knight bd7 you don't want
to step to c6 interfering with your
bishop you would much rather come out to
c5
and support this knight on f6 where you
can continue
bombarding the e4 square white plays the
move bishop e3
aiming at some dark squares in black's
camp and now black plays this move
bishop c6
just improving the bishop and perhaps
preparing to battle for e4 even more
strongly
the bishop dropped back to f2 in this
game and indeed we do see queen b7
tal just increases the pressure on e4
and it's sort of arriving at
a breaking point for fisher
so we have one two three attackers on
the e4 pawn white has two defenders
so he brings the rook over to defend a
third
time and now is where the game gets
really really interesting thus far i
think black is just playing very very
logical
chess very simple chess you know
responding to the threats that white was
making early on
getting his pieces developed to the most
natural squares and after seeing f5 he
took the opportunity to misplace
the white knights and pressure the e4
pawn but now
it's sort of decision time for black
you've
added just about as much pressure as you
can to this e4 pawn
and you have to figure out how you're
going to continue
in this chess game so uh chatroom black
to move
what do you guys think would be good for
black
in this position go ahead and take a
second to think
uh notably we would love to play the
move knight c5 but this square
is pretty hotly contested at this point
pretty hotly contested
what are your ideas chat room what do
you think
um yeah there are a couple ideas in the
chat
uh somebody wants to play the move rook
a to c8 and this is sort of the natural
looking move
that would definitely appeal to me as
well in these positions
i think the issue with playing this
slowly here
is that white might actually be able to
start untangling his pieces
for example a move like c4 might come
which
isn't exactly the move you would expect
but if you continue playing slowly
something like rook f2 d8 white's gonna
play something
like queen e2 and bring this bishop back
into the
back into the game and uh start
untangling his pieces like i said it's
it's not so easy to see how black is
going to break through
once white clamps down on d5 and starts
you know to reroute his pieces bringing
things to the center
i don't think black is ever going to be
worse here
but it's easy to see how white can sort
of consolidate the position
but as you guys suggested the move d5
is correctly timed in this position just
taking this opportunity to open up the
center
thanks to the misplacement of in
particular
uh these two pieces these two pieces are
not ideally placed for whites and
because of this lack of harmony
black is very very ready to deal with
the opening of the center
whereas white very much is not notably
also
the queen not ideally placed directly
opposite the light squared bishop
for black so d5 is the fantastic idea
that tal employed in this position
in order to put the pressure on
bobby fischer now white really does have
to deal with this pressure to e4
there's no way really to deal with it
besides taking on d5 so this was seen in
the game
now knight takes d5 preserves this
bishop on c6
which is putting so much pressure on the
white position
now white has to struggle just to keep
g2
under control so knight e4 was fisher's
attempt
to block the diagonal but now just the
very simple
knight f4 by mihal tal and the pressure
on the diagonal is
is just mounting c4 was now tried by
bobby fischer this move that i mentioned
before
would have been good for white if black
had played a bit more slowly but now
with this diagonal open black really has
no
issues here at all all right and now
chat room
let's see if you can find the very
tall-esque
move that definitely would not be my
my first thought in the position but
does turn out to just be
completely crushing and this is what
this myth this is what makes this game
uh truly incredible to me is tal's next
move
so think like tal how can you just
break open the entire position for
whites
and just prove to him that he's getting
blown off the board
so great wolf is very much thinking like
tal but maybe a bit too much like
tau knight takes g2 i think is just a
bit too much
queen g2 and you'll be lucky to uh to
regain the piece
you'd be lucky very very lucky
it does look like something that tal
would play so jk
rowling uh in the chat suggest the move
knight f6 and i think knight f6
looks like a very very natural try uh i
think after knight f6
white would be forced to go bishop c2
and perhaps he's still holding on to the
position a little bit so it's mainly the
idea
of c4 is he's able to bring back one
more defender of the e4 square but
someone in the chat does have it
astapada with a fantastic move g6
this move is just absolutely absolutely
insane
uh white has nothing better i think
if he wants to seriously stay in the
game than to try
taking on g6
but now tal being a super genius
of course does not recapture this pawn
uh recapturing this pawn
is completely winning but why bother
your tal you just play the move f5 and
you say hey
buddy i know how pins work uh i was a
world champion before you
this is this is just this is just over
this is just dead
so g6 f takes g6 f5
by tal is just the legendary
legendary tao at his finest here g7 was
tried by fischer
tal takes the free pawn because why
wouldn't you queen g3 check now
is escaping from the pin but after king
h8 it's
quite clear that uh white's problems on
the g2 pawn are not going away any time
soon
knight ec5 was played in the game we
have captures
bishop takes by fischer and
tal just takes back on c5 knight c5
queen c7 just taking his time
now is tau because the pressure on g2
is just going to to absolutely win the
game there's no chances here really
for white to escape fischer tried to
move
queen to e3 and now tau
being very very mean brings more pieces
into the game with the move rook
sorry not rook a to d8 but rook a to e8
just defending
the e pawn once again showing incredible
patience
there's still nothing that white can
really do about this g
pawn if you try the move g3 just the
move knight h3 check is good enough
king f1 f4 and this king is
busted so rookie 2 was played instead
trying to defend but of course this is a
free exchange
that tal accepts and then bishop takes
g2
just to sort of uh you know stick it to
him right
and an attack on the c5 knight to end
the game
knight takes a6 was played queen a7
check takes takes
sorry takes check king h3 and then
tal does not even bother capturing the
knight on a6
he goes queen g7 with a checkmating
threat bishop d1 to try to defend
and rook e6 bringing the last attacker
into the game
and this is the move that forced
resignation by
bobby fischer and it's definitely not
every day
that you see fisher just get blown off
the board like this
it's pretty obscene actually what
happened to fisher in this game
but it is sort of the model game for
black in the fisher sozen attack i think
you get this superior position thanks to
f5 e5
where you just gain total control over
the light squares in the center
break things open and then checkmate the
opponent on the king's side
a really beautiful game by tau
yes hello hello to everyone so any
questions on this game any questions on
how
things went so so wrong for fisher so so
quickly
uh i will just do a brief recap we had
f4 the main idea in many fisher sozen
positions
but now after castles queen f3 queen c7
preparing b5 and bishop b7 white played
a little bit slowly in the opening just
castling
playing queen f3 and then f5 allowing b4
was the opening advantage for tau b4
e5 and bishop b7 to get the superior
positional edge
and then from here bishop c6 queen b7 to
increase the pressure
and the killer move d5 to break things
open
while white is uncoordinated takes takes
and then the tactical idea to end the
game with
g6 just getting a completely
crushing winning position with this idea
really incredible stuff
um all right let's get uh get along
to the next game here of course fisher
didn't have such a good time with the
white side of this game in the night or
but fisher himself was a big pro
proponent of playing the night or with
the black pieces
so i would be remiss if i didn't include
a game by him as well
here we have him against uh georgie uh
tringov not a player i'm super familiar
with
but uh a very good game by bobby fischer
that i want to take a look at here
it goes e4 c5 knight f3
d6 d4 takes takes knight f6
knight c3 a6 and we arrive at the main
starting position of the night or of
course last game
we saw tal dismantle the fischer sozen
attack
and in this game we're going to see
something bobby is
famous for which is bishop g5
e6 the main move here again once again
bishop g5 is sort of preventing the main
night earth move of e5 because now once
again
the d5 square is under white's control
thanks to this bishop
pinning this knight so we resort to e6
once again
as black now f4 and
the poisoned pawn variation is what
fisher helped pioneer in his day
and it is really one of the main
variations
for black against the bishop g5 night or
still in play today a really incredible
variation that has some pretty intense
tactical complications
but if all goes well for black black
should have absolutely no issues
uh tryngov at the time played the move
queen d2
which is sort of throwing down the
gauntlet saying go ahead
take my pawn and this pawn on b2 is
what's known as the
quote-unquote poisoned pawn
but we'll see i think there's some quote
it turns out
this pawn is not laced with too much
arsenic
to uh to get away with so fisher
takes the free pawn now tryngov plays
the main move here of rook b1
taking advantage of the newly opened
file and forcing black to waste some
time with the queen
now queen a3 has to be played and the
main move here
is in fact the move e5
uh nowadays i think players prefer to
displace this bishop and put it on
h4 in this variation but bobby just
leaves it on g5
and goes for the immediate d takes e5 f
takes e5
and knight f to d7 uh highlighting the
fact that this pawn
while very far advanced is going to be a
little bit
weak and nowadays we'll see
that really the only serious move here
for white is to play the move knight e4
uh challenging a lot of these dark
squares and doing something very very
important on top of that
so why do we think knight e4 is the main
move well let's take a look at the move
played in the game
and that's the move bishop c4 and what
you guys think
might be the refutation to this idea for
black
what can black do to sort of refute any
idea that's not
knight e4
so yeah angelos has the right idea uh
you have to play knight e4
because it not only pressures a lot of
squares for black but very very
importantly
prevents the move bishop b4 by adding
the queen as a defender of that square
now bishop b4 is just very very good for
black
however as we'll see in this game there
are some only moves that black has to
end up playing in order to
fully realize his winning position rook
b3
is of course the obvious move for white
now you have to defend the knight and he
should try to do it with tempo
the simple queen back to a5 now is
forced by black preserving the queen
and white goes ahead and castles the
king
black also goes ahead and castles the
king nothing too ridiculous so far
but now after the move knight takes e6
the complications sort of begin here
so i want to see if you guys can play
like fisher
and navigate the complications to
achieve a fully
winning position from here
you do have a huge leg up on most
players at the time
which is you know the position is
winning for black because i've just told
you
but you still have to navigate the
complications so
how do we want to play in this position
and what threats do we think white
is going to try to make
yeah q tunneler is saying he plays the
poisoned pawn but with
uh mvl's h6 inserted and if you haven't
seen the latest
chess openings explained it is on this
delayed poison pawn variation that mvl
does in the night or it's also
actually what i'm recommending i do
think it's a very
very nice way of dealing with uh dealing
with the bishop g5 najdorf
so chess king says just take the knight
lol and that is correct
other moves like knight takes e5 just
aren't gonna quite be
good enough here for black for example
if knight e5
the simple knight takes f8 and knight
takes c4
isn't really good enough queen f4 is
creating a lot of very very scary
threats
that you're gonna have to deal with here
on the king's side so you do have to
capture this piece
f takes e6 that's the first sort of
hurdle to overcome
you guys did it uh bishop takes e6 check
is of course going to be played king h8
is the only move
and now after the move rook takes that
fate with check
how should we recapture this rook
well taking with the knight hangs the
bishop
not ideal so we do see the move bishop
takes that fate
and now queen f4 is the follow-up
for whites and i would like to ask you
guys once again
to see if you can continue navigating
these complications
with black here how should black
continue after the scary looking move
queen f4 what's the idea
how do we stop white's threat after
queen f4
also what is white's threat after queen
f4
all very excellent questions
so the move queen e5 is suggested but
you might want to be a little bit
careful
uh might want to be a little bit more
careful than than queen e5 i think
so yeah great wolf has a fantastic point
queen f7
is sort of a huge threat and this is
what blackening gets to stop here
this is what black needs to stop
okay queen c5 is a check uh
white will likely move out of the check
after queen c5
it's not really a not really a
an idea it's just a single move right
queen c5 and then what
so angelo says we need to activate the
rook
uh which is a pretty interesting idea
pretty interesting idea i think
angelos is on sort of the right track
uh meaning to defend the king we need to
make use of at least some of these
pieces
sitting on their starting square
at least some of these pieces so let's
talk about this move queen takes e5
right unfortunately this is dropping
your piece on c8
and this is not in fact going to be a
winning position here
for uh for black knight bc6 for example
you can take this pawn as well
and all of your pawns start to fall and
turns out you're not even up a piece
anymore
right three pieces versus three so you
cannot play queen takes e5 so you need
something better
something better and knight takes e5
unfortunately is
is missing this bishop on f8 missing
this bishop on f8
but yeah ariane has the correct idea
which is the move played in the game of
knight c6
i think you can include queen c5 check
first if you want but knight c6
is the defensive idea that you need to
see and what is the point
well the point is uh what somebody else
mentioned a little bit earlier on in the
chat
after the move queen f7 we see the idea
queen c5 check king h1 and
the move to win the game here is in fact
this move
knight f6 the incredible idea
to defend the g8 square trade off the
bishops
and make use of this pin of the pawn to
the bishop
on g5 you have to play queen c5 first in
order to defend the bishop on
f8 but this is the defensive point that
fisher had to see in order to win the
game
in uh in this manner if you don't see
knight f6
going to be very very difficult to
actually win this game so
crazy stuff but it is good enough the
move bishop takes c8 came on the board
and now the inner mezzo knight takes e5
is good enough for black
queen e6 knight e to g4
and guess who's getting checkmated now
turns out it's actually going to be
white
and white just resigned in this position
if he tries to solve the checkmating
threat with something like h3
we can give this check and just take
back our piece here
and uh black is going to be sorry we
probably want to take back
this piece instead and uh black is just
going to be up a full piece
and white's king is is likely going to
get checkmated uh very very quickly
black might even have something better
here after h3 i didn't really bother
to check actually yeah he does just have
stuff like bishop uh bishop out to d6 as
well
and i would be very very surprised if
white was able to survive something like
this
but maybe this is a little bit
needlessly complicated at this point
i don't know the point is black wins in
like every variation uh after
knight e to g4 which is why uh tringoth
went ahead and resigned
in this case so this one was sort of a
win out of the opening
for fisher just to recap but it was a
very nice game
in the night earth showing even when
you're winning out of the opening
it can still be tricky and you have to
find some really clever defensive ideas
like this crazy move knight c6 with
knight f6 to follow
in order to save black's king really fun
stuff
uh with that one in the books let's move
on
once again to our third legendary chess
player known for playing the night or
and that of course is the one the only
gary kasparov uh all-time legend gary
kasparov
was another huge proponent of the night
or like i said it's sort of the opening
of world champions it's an opening that
has been
um used by some of the best chess
players of all time and in fact
i dare say most of the best chess
players of all time have played the
nidorf as part of the repertoire at some
point in time
but let's jump into it here we have e4
c5
knight f3 d6 d4 takes takes
knight f6 knight c3 a6 and we have
another bishop g5
in this time with e6
f4 and now rather than the poisoned
pawn variation or the slightly different
variations with
bishop e7 queen c7 or knight bd7
or the delayed poison pawn with h6
kasparov chose none of the above in this
case
and went with the move 7b5 and this is
not one
that you see too often these days
anymore because
i do think there is a line where white
gets a pretty significant edge
and that comes about after the very
natural e5 highlighting the fact
that hey stupid uh your knight's pinned
i'm gonna attack it and then take your
knight for free
of course the story doesn't quite end
there there's queen c7
with checking ideas but for example
e takes f6 queen e5 bishop e2 queen g5
castles rook a7 is needed for some
reason i don't ask me why i didn't do
too much research into this
uh queen d3 rook d7 now
knight e4 queen e5 knight f3
queen takes p2 queen e3 or something
and apparently here white is like
scoring very very well i don't want to
go
too in too deep into it but if you're
curious why you don't see b5 so often
these days
it's because of this line with e5 if you
play
uh against if you play this line with
white maybe it's worth knowing if you
play it with black i would suggest
avoiding playing b5 here because that
line does look pretty uncomfortable
but in this game we saw none of that uh
the player with the white pieces
either did not yet know about e5 i don't
know if this was like a thing that
people knew about
in those days but instead chose the move
a3 which is a little bit of a calmer
approach
in order to prevent the move b4 and the
game continues
rather normally from here on out
we have the move bishop b7 and now ideas
with e5
are going to be much worse than they
were initially because these
uh this sorry this trait of moves a3
free bishop b7 of course
very much benefits black in any of those
ensuing complications
uh in the game queen e2 was chosen which
is now
very much threatening to go e5 with the
pawns over defended by the queen
bishop e7 is gary kasparov's choice now
to break the pin
and we do see queen side castles by
whites
knight bd7 by black and now g4
by white and the reason i wanted to go
over this game
yes this line with b5 is a little bit
out of date
you don't see too many players going for
it so often
but once we arrive at this position it
very much looks like
some mainline stuff that you would see
in
uh in openings like the poison pawn
where white goes a3
to keep the pawn on b2 uh you see stuff
like this
sort of all the time so i definitely
think it's worth
talking about here and now in the game
uh kasparov plays a couple moves that i
actually
sort of disagree with here uh so what
are
black's main ideas in a position like
this
what do you guys think some main ideas
for black here
main ideas for black and uh in this
variation
even if you're not familiar with this
particular line of the nidorf you should
be able to
notice some ideas just based on
what you can see now over the board
so yeah there are a lot of good ideas um
something you guys are mentioning
is of course the b pawn push uh this is
always going to be on black's mind
in these cases and so you guys want to
play moves like rook c8
queen c7 in order to make that push a
little bit more
more powerful and definitely this is
always an important idea in the
narrative night or
but i don't think it's the most relevant
just yet i mean rook seed is always a
good improving move
but for example after something like
bishop g2
the story doesn't end so other ideas
ah so tomas has some very good ideas
where rook c8 not so much with the idea
of pushing b4
but definitely with the idea of just
snatching this knight off of the c3
square
this is a very thematic exchange
sacrifice in the night or and it's one
of the very important ideas that we'll
see crop up
in this game
so aryan has some of those other ideas
that i was looking for
which is to do things like knight c5
with the point being
we're very much challenging this e4 pawn
uh sorry
and it on a good day we might sometimes
play the move d5
and sink a knight into the e4 square and
i think those are gonna be the two most
relevant ideas in this position
and with all of that in mind kasparov
plays the move queen b6
which i don't actually think was the
most accurate
perhaps he was thinking of playing some
b4 move and taking back with the queen
activating his pieces in this manner but
i don't think it's quite the most
accurate idea here i would have
preferred to see a move like rook c8
immediately creating threats of taking
on c3 or even something like knight c5
in many cases
the point being we are very much
challenging uh white's claim
to this e4 pawn that being said if
knight c5 immediately there might be
some problems with things like e5 in the
future
and the move bishop g2 might be good
enough to uh to hold everything together
but okay queen b6 is a fine move it's
not like black is much worse or anything
uh bishop h4 was chosen by whites in an
attempt to reroute this piece all the
way back
and now we do see the move knight c5 by
kasparov
bishop g2 by whites now i would like you
guys to try and find
gary's next attacking idea here it's
uh an idea related to those that we were
mentioning a little bit earlier on
but uh not one that i think got a
specific mention by anyone in the chat
what's the next attacking idea for uh
for black here uh yeah so i was
mentioning e5 in those cases
uh after the immediate knight c5 because
uh the black queen would still be
opposite this rook on d1
uh with the queen not on this file then
e5 of course is is really not going to
be
not going to be the idea for uh for
white
see ariane has it again the move knight
a4
is a really nice attacking idea for
black in many
of these cases and we see it come into
full effect here
point being we are shaking loose this
defensive knight from c3
and in this case white just takes on a4
we have b takes a4
but now we have two wide open files that
we can use to attack the white king
white continued pretty naturally with
the move g5
and gary steps this knight out of the
way
and this bishop comes all the way back
now to e1 to try
and take control of more of these dark
squares on the queen side
uh gary felt the time was right now to
castle being ready to bring in
more pieces into the attack and after
the move h4
he plays very very patiently brings one
rook to one open file
bishop c3 and another rook to another
open file
uh okay we see the move rook h3 now
and one more preparatory move for gary
bishop a8
to unleash the full force of these major
pieces
and now after queen g4 i would like you
guys
once again to find gary's next attacking
idea
ariana was talking about e5 for black
yeah e5 for black not going to be so
common you will see it
sometimes when white pushes f5 it can
very much be a good idea after white
pushes f5
to play the move e5 to keep things
closed but with the pawn on f4
e5 doesn't make as much sense in many
cases most cases i'll say
see of course you guys all have the idea
here you
just snatch this guy off of c3
and tell your opponent he's checkmated
whether or not he believes you
is another matter uh white's best
defense
is with b takes c3 rather than taking
with the rook if you take with the rook
queen takes b2 comes anyways and uh
white is facing many of the same threats
uh and now what's the follow-up what's
the follow-up for gary
you snatched the guy off of c3 uh but
what's the follow-up and ins verma says
just the move
knight c5 and that's going to be correct
here it's
sort of tempting to play a move like
queen b2 check
but it's not actually going to get you
anywhere immediately
you can take a pawn on a3 but your
attack is sort of stalling out now
right this king is finding safety in the
center of the board
so instead gary focuses on taking away
some of these squares from the king with
the move knight c5
keeping an eye on the e4 pawn when the
knight would be very very well placed
to prevent this king's escape route on
d2
white at this point decided he needed to
try and check paint black as well
so he plays the move f5 and then as i
was mentioning a moment ago
e5 for black is usually a very good idea
after f5 to keep everything closed
and we do see gary play it here so e5
for black
knight e2 and now uh a really
interesting idea
by gary uh is this move d5
uh breaking everything open once again
as we saw in the tile game
uh gary uses it here to take advantage
of the fact that the white king
is going to be checkmated if it can't
find safety in the center
because of this idea he plays d5 trying
to open the center
to make sure that that king in fact is
not going to be safe
over there uh now
perhaps white's best try would be to
play the move e takes d5
when after the move e4 uh
white might actually be doing doing well
uh he can play the move king d2
and actually start to to successfully
escape but
it's sort of understandable how this was
missed in the game
uh things like queen b2 are still going
to be very scary knight b3 checks are
always going to be ideas with queen
takes c2 coming next
but in the game none of that was played
and f6 was played instead and this of
course
now allows gary to play like a
mastermind
and go ahead and win the game so black
to move and win
what do you guys think here black to
move and win
yeah so d5 turns out not to be the best
move in that case
uh i think instead of d5 just to jump
back for a moment
queen b2 check would have been a little
bit simpler uh and the point here
is you can just start collecting on a
three
uh like it or not it is sort of time to
to collect this pawn
if you're not on c5 you're not going to
lose the uh the pawn on a4
ever and white gets some kind of attack
here
but after something like bishop d8 black
is definitely still fighting back
on the queen side and these ideas are
not so
so weak after all but d5 was you know
the
the most combative try trying to open
things up
see a knight take c4 is definitely the
start bishop takes c4 is the obvious
move for white
otherwise this is checkmate if i can
draw an arrow
so bishop takes c4 and now we have the
nice inner meso of bishop takes a3 to
preserve our peace
king d2 d takes e4 and now the end is
just sort of near
for white he goes king e1 but bishop c5
is once again cutting off the king's
escape route and after queen f5 we'll
see that black has more than one idea
and starts going with the a pawn to just
make a queen and this is enough
to win the game in this case queen takes
c5 a2
c4 and now e3 cuts the rook off from the
defense of the queen side as well
knight c1 challenges this pawn here
but some pretty impressive final tactics
now
by gary bishop d4 is a great
interference tactic
to keep the queen away from a1 you
cannot take with the rook
because black will be able to just uh
just queen
i believe right i think so
instead queen takes b8 was played by
white
but now queen takes b8 knight takes a2
queen f4 and black has an extra queen
and black's extra queen is going to be
able to deliver checkmate
uh in fairly short order thanks to the
power of these bishops as well
and so eolian went ahead and just
resigned this position
and the reason i wanted to go over this
game wasn't because it was a perfect
game
uh games in the night or rarely are
perfect because they just tend to be so
complicated with so many attacking
ideas but i wanted to highlight this
game because gary
does pretty much every principled move
in the night or that you can see here
just to go back through them in this
middle game uh
you see him go uh knight c5
pressuring e4 you see him go knight a4
opening up the files another classic
nidorf idea
you see him go uh
rook b8 rook c8 and go for an exchange
sack
on c3 just every classic night earth
idea in the book
you see gary go for and then you see him
try and convert
uh with pretty good technique that move
d5 does turn out to give the advantage
to white
but every other move gary played was
essentially correct which is pretty
insane
in such a complicated and difficult
position
so very fun game by uh by gary
okay let's move on i think we have time
for just
one more here before we get going uh
this time i want to
jump back to one by bobby fischer
and we're gonna see a slower type of
game in the niadorf here
so once again same opening moves as
always to
enter the night or and here white went
bishop e2
which is sort of seen as the more solid
more safe more positional lines in the
night or
compared to what we had been seeing with
all the bishop g5s in the bishop c4s
and the the craziness that ensues there
so after bishop e2 unlike bishop c4 and
bishop g5
this move does nothing to influence d5
so black is quite happy to play the move
e5
uh white goes knight back to b3 now once
again
if knight f5 the move d5 is strong uh
which is what bishop c
bishop c4 and bishop g5 both prevent so
knight b3 here
and now uh black goes bishop e6 which is
still
sort of a well-respected line but uh
what fisher is sort of baiting here is
the move
f4 unfortunately the question of whether
or not f4 is good for white is still
sort of up
for uh up for debate uh it does look
rather scary
for black to allow this line which is
why bishop b7 is much more common these
days
the point being now if f4 we don't need
to necessarily put our bishop here where
it could be vulnerable to f5 attacks
but could just bring it out to the the
queen side instead
so bishop e6 though white does not
immediately go for f4 instead choosing
castles
now knight bd7 and white does play the
move f4
here uh fischer now needs
uh someplace to put this bishop he
chooses queen c7
planning to drop it in into c4 after f5
we see him do
just that with bishop c4 and now the
move a4
is played for white and this is a
typical idea to challenge the b5 square
so what do i mean when i say that the
bishop e2 lines tend to be a little bit
slower a little bit more positional
well we'll see that white while he still
has pushed f4
f5 has also castled king's side
so we're not going to get those crazy
positions with opposite sides castling
where both players are sort of playing
for checkmate instead we're going to see
the player revolve a lot around the
queen side which is why you see white
play a move like a4
keeping b5 in check now black does
finally develop the dark square bishop
with the move bishop e7
we see bishop e3 for white still just
natural development
black goes ahead and castles sorry
castles and white plays the clamping
move a5
in order to lock down on b5 sort of
forever uh now i would like to ask you
guys at home
uh what do you do with the black pieces
in
positions like this what are some ideas
for black
to try and liberate his army just a
little bit
you've developed all your minor pieces
more or less you've castled the king
but what's the next step for black
because it looks like white
is doing a very good job of getting sort
of a clamp on the queen side right all
of his minor pieces
are aimed at that side of the board so
what do you do
what can be done
yeah great wolf i suggest playing bishop
e7 delaying bishop e6
for this exact reason because f4 f5 does
tend to be a little bit scarier
than uh then we need to allow so sunil
and tomas
both are suggesting the move d5 any
other ideas
philip says d5 anything else is there
any other idea besides d5
for black
alright we're four for four on people
suggesting d5
maybe that's it maybe that's the epitome
of the night or if you just play the
move d5 and
try and get them
so in this case d5 is is losing a pawn
right
like by my math you're just losing a
pawn here
free pawn so unless you have some sort
of extreme justification here
you're going down a pawn guys going down
a pawn isn't great
and okay now we have some more ideas
so great wolf is remembering a maneuver
involving bringing the bishop back to d8
trying to activate it
along this diagonal and it's not the
worst idea ever
it's really really not in this case with
the pawn on a5
it's a little bit more difficult to make
work although there are still definitely
some ideas of bringing the bishop back
and then playing
for the other idea being mentioned of b5
with the bishop controlling the b6
square in fact in the game
b5 immediately is what was played and
this is sort of a very standard way
of black achieving counter play in these
slower variations of the night earth
going for b5
allowing a takes b6 and knight takes b6
and playing for the opening up
of these files this is a great way to
play
generally in these positions d5 is not
going to be the idea it's
rather difficult to get d5 through quite
often and i think this is one of those
cases
rook f to c8 by the way is definitely a
playable move
and i think it's one well we're thinking
about king h1 for example is an
improving move and then we can continue
with something like b5 if bishop takes
c4 for example queen c4
queen f3 even now these moves like
bishop d8
do start to become a little bit more
realistic rick f
d1 for example queen c6 and at the end
of the day
we still are going to go for something
like b5 this is still just
the liberating move for black there are
a lot of different subtle
variations uh subtle changes to how you
go for b5
if you want to rook on c8 first if you
don't but at the heart of it b5
is the great idea for black to liberate
his queen side
and it was played immediately here so a
takes b6
knight takes b6 uh we see bishop takes
b6
which is not the best move in this case
king h1
is a bit more accurate stepping off of
this long
open diagonal and allowing black to uh
to play a bit more uh just for example
uh king h1 rook f2c8s
takes takes takes
takes queen e2 rook b4
rook a2 and it's uh a little bit tough
for black
to keep a hold of this a pawn but black
does get some nice pressure
against uh against these queen side
pawns instead though in the game
uh the slightly less accurate bishop
takes b6 was played immediately
and now after the check and back uh
black does have a bit of an improvement
over the last line that we saw
where we saw a rook being drawn out to
c4
instead now bobby comes up with this
nice idea of bishop b5
being able now to recapture on b5 with
the pawn
and fix his weakness on the queen side
excuse me my goodness uh bishop takes b5
was played in the game a b5
now the knight jumps into d5 speeding up
a bit because i'm running out of time
but that's okay
uh knight takes d5 of course has to be
played queen d5 white's not interested
in this change of structure and now
after rook a4
uh black is able to put pressure on this
e4 pawn
which of course is the downside to
pushing this pawn all the way up to f5
and he's not giving up control of the a
file either
in fact he's quite uh seriously
threatening to take over the a file
as white is not going to be happy to
take on a4 and allow this queen
into the game c3 was played but now
queen a6 by fischer
h3 by white uh white has sort of
strapped four moves here tough to come
up with an active plan
for him at this juncture honestly so he
plays a simple move like h3
trying to improve his king but now after
rook c8s
uh fischer is sort of just breaking
through rook fe1
comes on the board just defending
h6 for black makes left for his own king
king h2
and now bishop g5 activating black's
last piece
g3 queen a7 is
making some threats perhaps white is now
regretting playing g3 king g2 to guard
the squares
rook a2 king f1
and now i would like you guys at home to
find the final move
of the game what did fischer play in
this position
to totally end the game against
wolfgang unzinger unzikr
uh and yeah tomas has a question about
bishop takes b3 which i'll get back to
in a little bit
so yeah everybody sees the tactic rook
takes c3 is the
very very clever final move of the game
that uh just destroys everything and
everybody sees b takes c3 queen f2 mate
but did you see rook takes a2
how do you win after rook takes a2
uh of course you win with the move rook
f3 check
king e2 rook f2 check
king d3 and after queen takes a2
rook a1 queen takes b2 it's a good thing
we made left for our king
because now we get to check mate black
all right checkmate white in the center
of the board
uh with something like rook d2 queen d2
uh coming and checkmate or just queen c2
immediately as well
everything is checkmate here all rights
uh so very beautiful game by bobby
fischer i did want to jump back
to this question a moment ago uh there
was a question here
about uh bishop takes b3
i suppose it was and so yeah bishop
takes b3
c takes b3 would come on the board and
the issue here
for black is that this bishop for white
is is going to be pretty powerful right
he's just sort of taking over the light
squares
on the queen side even if you win both b
pawns in exchange for the a pawn white
is going to have a lot of activity with
this bishop
and bishop c4 in particular is going to
be
just a monster piece defending b3
defending d5
pressuring f7 pressuring a6 and i think
white is taking over
on the queen side at this point there
are
some variations in the nadorf i should
mention
uh that go with something like this
and knight c5 but these variations are
normally only done
uh when you're ready to step to b4 and
you have very very serious threats
against the pawn on e4 or the pawn on c2
i can think of one or two where you end
up taking on
b3 in order to sort of get this activity
but now that i'm thinking about it most
of those variations are with the bishop
on b3 not the knight
i don't think you ever really trade this
knight for this uh this bishop for this
knight you take on b3 sometimes when the
bishop makes its way over there
but with with the knight there i don't
think so
uh all right any other questions before
we call it quits here for tonight's
lecture
um all right
well then i hope you guys enjoyed these
uh very uh very fun games that's that's
the best way i can i can describe them
they're just a lot of fun
these games in the night orf and uh
it's great to see uh how the best
players in chess history
have handled these very complex night of
positions
how the theory has changed over time and
how these ideas have sort of persisted
from the days of kasparov and all the
way back from the days of fischer and
michal tao
how those ideas sort of persist and
change forms throughout history
is really interesting to me and i love
going over these games
hopefully you enjoyed it as much as i
did that is it for us here tonight on
the road to 2000.
if you're watching live be sure to stick
around for the end game class which will
be going on
directly after this in just a couple
minutes uh
if you're watching the video version
once again thank you so much for joining
me as always my name is caleb dunby
and i will see you next time